so not only what do you do here at Khan
Academy High Khan Academy I am our
content localization program manager
which means I work on everything that
allows our content to be more available
and accessible to more people in more
places so what does localization mean
localization is a nice fancy way of
saying making the experience feel right
for you so if you're in the States for
example you might speak English and so
it makes sense for you to hit the Khan
Academy site in English or with content
that makes sense for your use case for
example if you're in school and it makes
sense for you to have maybe Common Core
aligned curriculum but if you are saved
not living in the United States then you
might not need common core curriculum
you might need something that's more
aligned to say your standards like if
you're in India maybe the ncert
standards or in Hindi for example so
that's one way to think about
localization was making the experience
right for you and how on a day-to-day
basis do you do work towards that goal
sure I kind of segment the way that I
think about my job in sort of two ways
one being internal what can we do to
make that experience really better and
externally like who do we need to work
with to make that happen so on an
internal side of things I work with both
product people engineers designers
developers etc to create the
infrastructure on a product side to even
make our content localizable so that's
what does that mean the infrastructure
on the product side sure so that means
we have tons of strings of words on our
website like a string and computer it's
just like a like a collection of letters
imagine a sentence that I am saying
right now that sentence needs to be
translated and so being able to sort of
extract that sentence and put it
somewhere so that people can translate
it and then take it back and put it on
the website in a different form is one
way you're thinking about making the
product localizable and so that means
you know making sure we have the
infrastructure in place to be able to do
that so that's the sort of internal side
making sure that we're set up for
success there and the external side it's
really working with the people who can
make translations happen from volunteers
to partner organizations
and to see who we can work with maybe
not inside of Khan Academy to help
spread the word or get us to our goal of
reaching more people and more places
faster who are these volunteers and
these partner organizations so the
volunteers are people from all over the
world who have found Khan Academy and
decided they want to volunteer their
time to translate our content you know
some of these people are we receive
applications from kids in high school
who are using Khan Academy right now in
English perhaps and say I really want to
have this in Swedish or in German and
they also could be teachers who have had
the ability to use the the product so
far and say well like this could be X
percent better if my kids could use it
in their native language from the
organization side these are you know
philanthropic organizations like the
lemon foundation in Brazil who work with
us to not only translate our content
they have a whole program of translators
in on their side of things but also who
can work with schools and do trainings
with teachers and their local context
they really understand what's happening
on the ground in a way that our small
80% team just can't right now so they
also help to you know work with
localization in a different way I see
and what languages is kind of kind of be
available in now right now we have full
platform experiences so that means
videos and exercises and all of the
strings on the platform coach resources
etc in Spanish Portuguese Brazilian
Portuguese and French with many more on
the way so that we've got Turkish we've
got German we've got Hindi tons of
translation projects and over 40
languages right now and so you know we
start talking little bit about your day
today so explain like what's going to go
on today sure or tomorrow well they're
probably going to be different answers
so today's Monday and usually when I
come in on Monday I sort of think about
okay what do I have to tackle this week
what are my as a column at Khan Academy
big rocks these are the things that are
really going to sort of move the
mountain of rocks and to actually make
make a difference and so I evaluate at
the onset of the week what are those big
rocks and how am I going to make sure I
have the time budgeted within the week
to do that things come up all the time
right but to-do list is pretty long and
so I'm carving out that
and is really important sometimes that
means to sort of go back to the internal
external side of things working more
internally with setting up new projects
that our product team can get started on
and sometimes that means you know having
several calls or meetings a week with
our external partners to make sure we're
aligned on what our big goals are so it
varies day today sometimes lots of alone
work sometimes lots of teamwork
sometimes lots of a book and what were
you doing before coming to Khan Academy
before coming to Khan Academy I was on a
Fulbright in Turkey where I was teaching
English at a university and it's
actually one of the reasons I ended up
coming to Khan Academy because I noticed
as most people do when they teach
English in a broad context that my
students weren't able to get over the
hurdle of just a language barrier let
alone mastering concepts and skills and
really being able to think about cool
things that language can provide you
with the opportunity to do and so I
noticed that firsthand in my work
experience but also I noticed when i was
living abroad that i was aching for you
know new learning experiences and
wanting to push myself further and
further so I actually used Khan Academy
when I was abroad just like relearn math
and re you know lubricate my brain
because I actually I love learning and
was really inspired by the product so
that's why I ended up after after my
Fulbright coming here and what's what's
it been like what's been surprising hmm
what's in surprising i think when i
think about the opportunity that we have
here at Khan Academy to reach millions
if not a billion people at some point
who haven't yet had the opportunity to
be impacted by what we're doing here
that kind of blows in my mind right so
maybe it's less a surprise than
something that gets me up every day and
coming to work that if there's one small
thing that I do that can impact even one
person that's a super cool opportunity
and a super awesome thing to work
towards so that's certainly been
exciting for me and other surprises
everyone here is is a giant goofball
great I think sometimes we think of the
work environment is being very strict
and you know we come in we have lots of
to do things and gotta get those big
rocks out of the way but like one of my
favorite things about working here is
going around in like giving people high
fives and having push-up contests at
random parts of the day just to get the
energy flowing so I think that's they
don't tell me about those since I did
the dollar I don't dominate Oh
interesting I'll invite you next time
and what are you excited about an hour
work yes or anything actually so with
regards to the work here at Khan Academy
we are you know several years into the
let's get our content translated idea
but now we're really able to focus now
that we've set the foundation here in
the US for who we are and what we're
doing and we've seen the great product
market fit here in the United States I
think we're really set up to make a big
impact in lives for people who don't
live here and maybe don't speak English
so that's naturally what excites me the
most about my current thing going on
here um other things going on in my life
that I'm excited about I don't know if
that's what you're asking I i just
started becoming I just trained to be a
yoga teacher oh wow that's exciting so
now I teach yoga maybe I'll bring that
to the company um and I won't see ya I
don't know what else just just I really
inspired it to work here in and it takes
up a lot of good brain space for me well
no thank you and you said get you up in
the morning just to help one person I do
suspect that the work you're doing well
well well in fact several tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions
hopefully yes so thank you know